it's great to welcome back to the
program today jonathan height who is an
author social psychologist and professor
at nyu's stern school of business he
recently wrote an article for the
atlantic called why the past 10 years of
american life have been uniquely stupid
jonathan always great to talk to you
thanks dave it's great to be back with
you so in the in the article you um talk
about a number of different things uh
you lead with the story of babel as a
sort of metaphor for what's happened in
the united states uh since the 20s
starting in the 2010s and the sort of
fractured nature of the country you talk
about social media you talk about
political discourse you've talked about
the impact of trumpism sort of on
discourse in society for people who
maybe have not yet read the article and
will link to it and everybody should
can you give us sort of a flowchart a
directional flowchart of the the
phenomena you observe sure yes uh thank
you for that for that it's a good setup
because we think in narrative we think
in stories things make sense what we're
going through now is so hard to
understand but if we tell the story it
goes like this um
in 1989 the berlin wall falls we have
this incredible period of optimism about
democracy this is also the period of the
early internet we have this incredible
period of optimism about technology for
those who remember the early internet
was this magical incredible place
um we get into the the early 2000s of
course we do have 911 we do have things
get a little darker but that decade
the early social media platforms uh the
optimism wikipedia i mean it was just
incredible what this technology was
going to do for democracy
i'd like to bring readers back now to
the peak year of 2011 a year that starts
with the arab spring and we think what
dictator can stand up to to people
empowered by facebook and other
platforms right um that year ends with
occupy wall street we think the people
empowered so 2011 we really is the peak
year of techno-democratic optimism
2012 barack obama's re-elected gay
marriage resolutions are passing all
around the country so it looks like this
direction to history is clearly one
direction and it be the direction that
would be favored by by progressives
and then everything goes to hell
beginning around 2014 a lot of weird
stuff happens in 2014. my argument in
the essay
is that tribalism is very old this left
right dynamic is very old but something
changed in the 2010s that made us afraid
of each other that made it very easy for
people to intimidate each other and that
leads to fragmentation within the left
fragmentation within the right
and the key metaphor
if you go back to the tower of babel
story in genesis it's very short little
story the key line is that when god is
offended by humanity's hubris he says
let us go down and confuse their
language so that they may not understand
one another and that's what's new the
break it's not just the it's not the
cross-party hatred that's been going on
for a while we've had that before it's
this new thing of just everything
breaking up we can't understand each
other
that piece reminds me you know
oftentimes people will talk about
orwell's 1984.
but what you just mentioned about the
confusion
is really more reminiscent to me of
aldous huxley's brave new world where
it's a sort of you could say a fire hose
of falsehood or or this inability to
sort of discern what's real or what
isn't is is that an apt analogy to what
you're describing um it's you know there
are elements of both right we all read
you know at least from my generation we
all read those two works in ninth grade
or whenever it was yeah uh and that's
the way the 20th century thought about
things you know either it's going to be
you know dictators like stalin and
hitler or it's going to be some like
techno oppression
uh but neither of those anticipated the
decentralization revolution that is um
what what's happening now has some
echoes of you know the stasi in east
germany and people are afraid to speak
and people can rat on each other but
there's no dictator uh and so just as
you know i've been learning a little bit
about cryptocurrencies and you know
decentralized finance we've talked about
defy
in the same way you might speak about
detote that is there can be
decentralized totalitarianism without
any
totalitarian or any leader we can all be
afraid of each other and that has
effects that suppress discourse suppress
people dissenting on both sides
moderates in particular are afraid to
speak up because on the right you're
going to get death threats and and be
horrifically attacked on the left you'll
be called a racist or transphobe so
social media makes it very easy for the
passionate extremes to attack the
moderates and to attack leaders that i
think has messed us all up since around
2014. how did uh donald trump sort of
exploit the these circumstances
donald trump uh
the diagnosis i hear from my friends who
are clinical psychologists is
narcissistic personality disorder um he
everything's about him he is not an evil
genius he is not manic he's not like
this like brilliant mannequin behind the
scenes manipulator he is what he is he
is a narcissist uh with very little
self-control um and he just does what he
does and it just so happens
that the political world the
communications world went insane around
2014
to allow someone like him to actually be
out there tweeting um and you know we
have negative partisanship the more you
attack the other side the more people
like you on your side um so my argument
is that donald trump didn't cause the
collapse of the tower of babel he
certainly made things worse he made
everything worse made the passions worse
made the norms worse i mean i blame him
for a lot but had he never run
most of these things would still have
happened not quite as intense that they
would have still happened
um he benefited because
in the pre-babel era before we were all
fragmented people saying the things he
said like that was automatic exclusion
like everybody would have shunned him
you know but but afterwards nothing
makes sense anymore there is no
overarching narrative it's babble all
the way forward yeah one of the things
that i think resonates with me in terms
of understanding that period is
it seemed that it became much more
acceptable to publicly say a lot of the
things that before
some people understood i think this but
i probably shouldn't say it i shouldn't
say it at work i shouldn't say it on
social media it was sort of normalized
to some degree that's right well that's
right and there was such a thing as
polite society there were some norms
that were widely shared maybe not on the
far right and far left but there was a
sort of a you know a general consensus
of polite society and you could be
outside you could quickly get yourself
outside polite society
part of what i'm arguing is that
is that there's always let's let's say
how much voice does do people have at
each point on the on the spectrum and
it's always the case that people who are
angry and loud are going to have more
voice because they try harder so the
middle has less and the extremes have
more when social media comes in and i
don't mean early social media i mean
only after we get the like button the
retweet button that's 2009 we get
threaded comments in 2013 which
encourages everyone to fight with
everyone in the comments section
it's this new hyper-viralized
environment that's what changes things
and when that happens now the extremes
get much more voice and the middle 80
percent gets much less
many of us we just keep our heads down
people are exhausted they don't want to
speak up and we can't have a
deliberative democracy when most people
don't want to even join the discussion
and when the people in the discussion
are incentivized literally incentivized
to be assets the more of an asset you
are the more
you say things that are extreme the more
you will be successful so the incentives
are so antithetical to what we need in
our deliberative democracy
you talked about the spectrum there's
this book waves of rancor which i think
might might not even be in print anymore
which talked about the early days of uh
talk radio uh how it was dominated by
sort of uh conservative ownership as
well as by uh church radio low power
church radio and that this was part of
why the right started to dominate talk
radio now one of the things i also think
is a factor
is that these some of these platforms
are better vessels for some right-wing
ideas so like for example if you think
about taxes the right-wing idea of taxes
are bad maybe they're theft maybe
they're slavery let's just make them as
low as possible it's super simple and
concise and it's great for talk radio
the position on the left is not let's
make taxes as high as possible it's well
we need the right level of taxation to
account for the social programs we want
you right so it's already sort of like
structurally a problem is this to some
degree also a factor
but maybe
even more so when it comes to social
media the number of characters that are
allowed on twitter and this type of
thing
absolutely
if you think about the conditions under
which people can have a discussion when
they disagree
here's a really really bad way to do it
how about
let's bring people together and have
them be perhaps anonymous
let's bring people together have no
shared past no shared future it's a
temporary interaction
let's bring them together in a place in
which you guarantee that there is no
context whatever you say will be taken
out of context because there is no
context especially twitter twitter of
course being the worst of all um
and let's do it let's have this
discussion take place in the middle of
the roman coliseum
so that the stands are you're having a
discussion with someone but you're not
really talking to the person you don't
really care about the person the
audience
thousands of people all around cheering
for blood
some are on your side some on the other
person's side um now what are the odds
that you're gonna have a good discussion
about what do you think the proper tax
rate should be
what should we do about immigration like
you know you cannot have a discussion so
uh so your question started with talk
radio and that is a huge part of our
polarization that's something i didn't i
mentioned in the atlantic article i
should have said spent more time on
talk raider really does radicalize the
right in the beginning of the 70s but
especially in the 90s fox news
and all the talk radio stars
doesn't have a similar effect on the
left but i think my sense is that while
talk radio made the right radicalize in
the 90s
social media made the left radicalize in
the mid 2010s there's been a lot written
from matt iglesias originally and others
calling it the great awokening an
intensification of well you know
wokeness is the word used by the right
but
it really did change the dynamics on the
left there's always been a and there
still isn't the democratic party a
healthy debate between more the far left
and the moderate left so in the party
that dynamic is still going on whereas
in the republican party there is none
all the moderates are dead or expelled
so the republican party i say in the
paper the republican party has become
the stupid party you become stupid when
you shoot your moderates if you don't
have descent if you have orthodoxy you
become stupid you'll be wrong on most
things the republican party is the
stupid party the democrats are not but
my argument is that if you look in many
of our epistemic institutions that is
those that generate knowledge
universities media the arts journalism
these of course are dominated by
progressives that's always been the case
and it's very much the case now
when those places like the new york
times when people can't dissent within
a progressive organization then that
organization becomes structurally stupid
and so i think social media has
intensified the power of progressive
activists in a way that has often
suppressed dissent on the left and i
think that actually in the long run i
think that hurts the left yeah we talked
before the start of the interview about
how there is an asymmetry in how the
extremes on either side are sort of
impacted by the status quo i i'd love to
hear you talk a little bit about that
but i also think it's important to
mention
the extreme of the left however we
define it and i think sometimes what's
called extreme maybe isn't that extreme
by global standards but let's put that
aside for a moment it doesn't seem to
have that much power in the democratic
party as evidenced by on reddit and
twitter in 2020 it looked like bernie
was just running away with this thing
and it wasn't even close in terms of how
democratic voters actually voted in the
primaries
that's right no you're right it doesn't
have that much power within the party
and that's the asymmetry
there's there's a great quote from john
stuart mill it's something like in all
of the great disputes about social
matters each side has been right in what
it affirmed though wrong and what it
denied
and when i talk to people on the left
they can i mean the number of crimes
committed by the republican party
certainly from denying barack obama's
supreme court appointment to trying to
storm the capital to overturn i mean the
crimes are it's unbelievable the crimes
the republican party has committed and
there is no comparison to what the
democrats have done so people on the
left are certain of that and they're
right they're absolutely right
why don't those damn republicans realize
that well not talk to conservatives
there you know some will acknowledge
that yeah you know the party you know
i'm not so comfortable with this but
and then boy do they have a list of
crimes of what the cdc did what the
media did what the universities did and
they could they've got videos and
they've got quotes and their quotes from
people that you know so here's what i'm
saying there's this giant asymmetry and
it's as in an argument between two
spouses each side
they've got their list of violations the
other and they don't match up it's not
we're not talking about the same thing
um so that's why you know look i've
always been on the left i was always
trying to help the democrats
speak more intelligent about morality
that's why i got into political
psychology
um but when i wrote the righteous mind
in 2011 i was writing at 20 10 11 i
began to get concerned like oh my god
actually our country is coming apart i
mean the partisanship is becoming
outrageous this is really dangerous and
so i started focusing more on how do we
fix our institutions get our political
game working so that we can address
these problems
and now i'm in a state of complete panic
because i think if you look at the
trends we are so far from
we're so far from even understanding not
just the other side but what our own
side is doing we are so confused we are
basically lost in babel
last thing i want to ask you about and i
know our time is not unlimited um if we
narrow down a little bit and think about
if and how social media should be
managed or regulated based on your
interpretation every idea is out there
from no regulation whatsoever just like
allow everything and let it police
itself to we need some kind of
nonpartisan government board but who
decides who's on the board and all of
the problems that come with that
what what where is your thinking on this
at this point okay well so first so my
thinking is first please stop talking
about content moderation and you framed
it the way everyone does is are we gonna
have more or less no i don't want to
talk about that because it's the
question is just are we going to move it
up or down a little bit elon musk would
have moved it down we'd write less
moderation democrats
no that's not where the action is so
what's the right question
but the right question is uh
what is this what is this technology
this platform that has changed our
discourse what is the architecture what
are the dynamics of this new platform
after 2009
that has made it not
we're never going to stop people from
posting crazy nonsense but why is it
that after 2009 the crazier the nonsense
is the further it goes
what changed and how can we unchange it
and so there's two things the first
thing to attend to is who
who is on the platforms and here right
now any russian agent can create a
thousand accounts a day and run them
either personally or with bots any jerk
any [ __ ] and there are people who are
trolls who have personality disorders
they get to harass as many people as
they want they get to make death threats
nothing happens maybe they can't get
shut down they can make 100 more
accounts
so the first thing is we must have
uh user verification you can still post
with a fake name but to get an account
with posting privileges we can't just
let everyone make a thousand fake
accounts that's insane
um so any large platform and elon musk
even proposed this at least partially
but ident authenticate users so that's
one pay attention to whether we whether
you have to at least show you're a
person and old enough like that would
cut down on a lot of it the second thing
um is the dynamics of amplification
right now the incentives are the nastier
you are the further you go let's try to
reverse that so it'll be very easy for
facebook or twitter to um quantify using
ai and and percent human coders how
aggressive is each person you get an
aggression score all you do is say you
know screw you jerk with exclamation
points you get a five you're like you
know overall on average you're a five on
a one to five scale
and what i'd like to see is when we
start to open an account your default is
the filter set to four
so um i will see only people are four
and below and the people are five i
don't see them they don't see me i don't
want them in my public square they don't
belong in the public square um now if i
want to lower my filter to 3 or 2 i can
do that if i want to see the ass i can
raise it to 5.
if we did that
the incentive would not would be no
longer be as much of an as you can it
would be you know what if you're a
complete ass you're going to lose most
of the world they're not going to listen
to you so that's the sort of change
that'll be completely transformative
whereas the eternal argument about more
or less content moderation who decides
and where's the line that hasn't gone
anywhere in 100 years 200 years it's
never going to go anywhere
uh absolutely fascinating ideas we've
been speaking with jonathan height uh
the article in the atlantic is called
why the past 10 years of american life
have been uniquely stupid jonathan
always really appreciate your insights
thanks so much david let me just end by
saying i put all my resources on a
single web page if you go to jonathan
height dot com slash social media i have
everything you could want to know about
the effects of social media on teen
mental health and on democracy links to
hundreds and hundreds of academic
articles so that's a sort of a one-stop
shop where i show my work